hey Mary what you say how much a
pleasure well I feel like I feel like
you're a lot more friend
Hey I see your face like most day so I
appreciate it
me and Gary be up in the office guru
Ramdev a wolf into corporate talk about
ownership and average KPI detectors that
outlet average I'm spending zero time in
Asia it's crazy just well serendipity
and alpha change them yeah that's about
the changing for know what the rack'em
depth is not blogging in August for my
family
I hope you the proper brands predator
weather
so one mate at 7:37 405 745 walk it Hong
Kong baby I [ __ ] love it I really do
what feels good I like it
I like you dealing with that virtually
indie rock not personally good for you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
how are you blast doors again I'm just
one time here this is your first trip
you yeah so I went to I came you on a
cell for math okay so this is your first
trip yeah exactly
cool super math challenge to nurse
everybody in the middle to your point is
in real trouble production companies
that know how to make good content but
are stuck in the middle not super
premium they're trying to make volleyer
they're dead and then like if you make
it like you know the cost of entry of
making content to your point is not very
high if you knew and you've only come
from this world people run a business
how can we think run creditor
because I'm going to popular question
the answer is a lot less than any of us
realize when you start realizing at
least that I've start to realize is it's
unbelievable how can people actually run
a company no matter its size you know
how they have that thing where you can
only have 150 contacts or something I
have a funny feeling there's a business
version of that where there's only like
six eleven people that can actually run
a company for me just completely upset
from suffocating excuses because then
good stuff happens
excuses are the currency that allow you
to not act well thank you thank you them
that's your name is Mary Mary nice to
meet you Mary and I extra say hello
thank you yes thank you you're
comfortable oh yeah hi how are you six
thank you I would have said I wanted
this up in China it's all right it's it
I'm feeling really good must have been a
long flight uh I got to tell you like
I'm obsessed with long flight
[Music]
I started Wine Library TV in February of
2006 and probably summer of o-5 is when
I basically said I'm no longer a liquor
store wine store owner I'm going to
learn everything about this Web 2.0
thing and you're and you know somewhere
no six it became very much on my radar I
remember it for a long time I did a wine
event at technorati
as the help pouring like the firm like I
really need to do you know what you rock
we really need to talk about this the
first six four five or six tech events I
ever did I was basically the bar I
basically I email I'll never forget this
I emailed Leo Laporte Leo Laporte did a
guy coup do you know which I COO was Jay
coup was one of Twitter's two
competitors and I was in New Jersey and
I need to know how big or small meetups
were I emailed them cold because I saw
it somewhere and I was like can I pour
wine at the event so I flew to San
Francisco and stood behind a table like
this and just poured wine
[Music]
you should be betting the farm as I am
on having a skill or a briefing that
penetrates my morning My Morning News my
first four minutes for all your
businesses this will play out this is
what I'm excited about for me to play in
Asia and anywhere else in the world
there are certain things that are just
core humid and then you have culture but
if you keep whittling it down to core
human there's always opportunities if
you understand it time is core human
buying and selling time is a big [ __ ]
business sound audio is about to be the
next frontier and it's open now it's
kind of open its open for a lot of us
who build on top of infrastructure like
Amazon Apple Google are not going to
give up what they have it's but when
you're sort of looking at things like
one in every five Google search engines
searches are done by voice like like
Google needs to be scared shitless of
Amazon winning Alexa and I don't know
what's happening in Asia with boy like
so what's happening in Asia has voice
triggered yet do we have a Lexus skills
is anybody launching on because kind of
like huge so to me for you so that
sounds interesting Malaysia the voice is
already a very good communication
platform so we can't really blew up
voice because they had voice messages
yet before what that is under civilian
air speakers of the language so people
are used to the more thing this is
accurate correct
so now consumption avoid so to me every
single person that brushes their teeth
in the world will be listening to
information the first I am obsessed with
the first seven minutes of your day like
that is going to be won by voice it's
gonna be passive consumption for a
generation until the next technology so
I've already got an Alexa briefing
garyvee 365 it's either motivational
it's informational like to me that's
where media companies can win some
interesting arbitrage that hasn't been
thought of yet it's the same old game we
were we were going for blogging and
email and RSS feeds right before that I
was doing
email then it became Twitter followers
like it just what's so amazing for all
of us
is if you understand the pattern
behaviors it never ends
you just have good euros and bad eras
you just got to stay alive when founder
stole is a global highschool bootcamp
for high school students to become
entrepreneurs so good one thing that
you'll learn you're so young right now
you guys are so young right now you
don't realize you know how the hell is
everybody here 14 15 16 12 to 7 so one
thing that will blow your mind is that I
sit here right now with you at 41 years
old and I feel like I'm just like you I
remember how I felt at 14 and it feels
exactly the same way I feel 41 you can't
imagine how much fire and passion and
how young you feel at 41 like when I was
14 15 16 17
41 feeding like dead I get it it wasn't
that long ago right when you get to 41
and you realize you feel exactly the
same way you feel right now then you
start betting on patience and I think
patience is a very important part of
this game is your lumber in there was a
week I mean I think a lot of young
people make decisions that are
detrimental in the long term because we
want instant gratification because they
don't realize how long life is big sizes
Gary as you so much you're welcome
[Applause]
awesome yes of course
also bridges thank you guys from Chris
I'm Joey - pleasure
how are you bye guys bye bye provide be
the influencers FLL yeah that's right
good pressure what is it again quickly
within key opinion the analysis I came
out
so the Kol are they more often
cross-platform and they're big on four
or five different platforms are one or
two across popular what about audio
audio yeah well we both have like close
online radio that completely all sold
under the regulation each audio base and
I hear you can you know there are some
audios like when I joined you got a good
job you have a what starting to get you
a support opinion yes looks like with me
here you can link you can find book
righteous people and then people it
right up exploring and women know it's
good for sure people can't be anything
right now you can read somebody or not
like a YouTube video so that's obscene
like
right so thank you somewhere oh yes oh
thank you so much
salvation nothing like New Frontiers you
know thank you good thrilled to be here
first time in Hong Kong yes i DIF
arrived every one of us doesn't have to
be seven feet tall now the problem is a
lot of people can't be entrepreneurs
like it's hard to be a successful
entrepreneur oh yeah so how is your nice
day
and it goes to me hi do you want here to
see you thank you very much what's your
name Cousteau yes in each appeal the
church yes sure of course fine yes okay
you know problems are going to hitting
the right stage kind of go there to the
right yeah sure of course yeah I'm
crystal functions and such a pleasure
thank you for having smartphone
allergies please only
yeah thanks Xerox to me I think TB or
social these mobile devices you need to
start debating the notion of super high
quality mixed with bad lighting and bad
audio I think people yearn for visiting
I think so and I think you know I think
listen there's a place for 6-hour movies
like Avatar and there's a place for a
six-second you know bad lighting selfie
and I think they all work as long as the
message is extremely strong have you
always been a big sweater like I miss
Perriman yeah yeah quite a bit I mean uh
hey how are you hi how are you it's for
me all right guys all right I'm ready to
go he's got a question he the one good
thing about the Asian market is there no
shortage of FinTech companies one thing
that will resonate for everybody here
it's something I've been thinking a lot
more about I'm stunned at people's wants
to convince people of things selling to
the unsellable is a great waste of time
guys thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here we go I want a little bit of
pomp thank you very much bill okay
awesome Thank You Man thank you very
nice
you know I always tell entrepreneurs and
really people like embrace your
differences because there are your
advantages I mean I don't believe that
video is the answer for everybody but I
do believe that video has the biggest
upside to impact one's business -
pleasure and so on cause thank you
there's just enormous opportunity that
that's clear as day like every startup
bit right anything I'm doing enjoy life
true man
but the problem is live streaming apps
in mainland China government doesn't
like how fast you're moving to censor
your out there's 150 of them a year ago
there's six now like you know like you
know I think it's tough enough to win
with consumer when you have the added
element of government those are some
interesting dynamics
hello Hong Kong what is completely
misunderstood is you don't get to be the
judge of quality content the audacity of
the media or thought leaders or
successful individuals or just a person
that they get the judge what is quality
content has been the opening that so
many people can take advantage of
content is suggestive thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you never waver it's no different than
muscles you have to do it every [ __ ]
day every day
yes every day just a mindset Thank You
yourself the way you get more customers
is by underpriced attention on a period
I love you thank you yeah that's right
what you're welcome thank you for saying
that she's awesome because thank you so
much it's such a blessing right you do
Hillary thank you so much I'm so
flattered you guys ready I really love
to comment for a long time you helped me
out so much as I'm working on my own
saga
oh so proud of you that's amazing how
old are you I'm amazing
what are you working on I'm working on
an eye startup so what we're doing is
what I'm doing it's a running execute
yeah we can I play the speakers with
learners presented distract and learn
together I love it where do you guys
live Oh
Hong Kong inaudible very nice I'm really
going nice so now I'm coming in October
it's so nice to meet you such a pleasure
Hillary thank you congratulations you
did a good job by Hillary I hope I see
you soon
I like life's funny bro the number one
ROI of conferences is engaging with the
other in 10 DS so yes I think that if
I'm willing to tell people not to watch
me and go meet other people it means
it's a huge ROI it's coming so if I
could be a help or you know thank you
talk sooner take care of one question
yes
so how health is very important for
business how he'll help has your
personal health is very important
entrepreneurship
if you die you're out of business if you
died thank you Gary
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes now that pro-life domination
[Music]
I said well yeah things are great
you have to share name on it
[Music]
pletely blown away like like it was it
like one of those few times in my life
oh it's instantaneous as soon as I hit
the ground this is your kind of place
bunch of respects things they survive in
a world where in especially Instagram
there's a narrative being painted around
entrepreneurship that is so ridiculous
that I passionate about showing the
truth to be very very very frank to core
things one I felt that the blog and all
the content I'm able to produce from the
blog would be a disproportional
advantage for me as a media company as
an arbitrage to brand awareness and
number two this is the thing I would
have learned from if I was watching it
when I was 13 because I was a bad
student but I'm very good visually
[Music]
native
[Music]
what gets traveled very far
it's a really anytime joining I really
must be a real watch foldability
what's up you sick [ __ ] exhausted finish
really
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
you